hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now I'm gonna do myself a solid favor
here and never ever ever ever play
Ross's levels ever again and that's
gonna add like 20 years to my life and
I'm gonna be a lot better off so instead
of hating Lux every time I see him I'm
gonna look up create a popular creators
and play their levels instead which I
did here and this level has a pretty
good clear rate it's pretty high
very well rated and not too terribly
shabby oh wait did I do bad did I new
bad already
it just started this I can't do bad this
early in the game do I need that one
wait a minute how the hell do I get up
there what huh okay hang on oh I am
stupid good oh this wasn't supposed to
go this way how the hell do you get up
there it's a down arrow okay so I was it
said there's a there's a good dong I
love me some good dong but there's a
good dong when I put this helmet on Oh
buddy boom oh oh okay that's what I was
supposed to do hey yeah make the right
choices that's so cool
woo I can't jump that high can I open
this HUP oh how am I gonna do that
there we go okay oh is this what it's
like to play an actually good level okay
it's not whoa easy up there chuckles
let's get a little bit of a Oh God I did
the bad but I can get rid of the bad and
do the good
frankly that was pretty amazing I'm
actually pretty happy about this oh this
is what actually created levels can do
okay I felt so good about myself I was
sure that did something wrong hey wait
how do I do this oh it's gonna do the
thing yeah I can't make it I'm too big
okay so this one yeah titty sprinkles
okay how about this one
Bing bong so what is this gonna do
that's so creative and interesting oh oh
this is really cool oh no wonder this
person has a lot of yes I'm totally
guessing at this point so I'm not
entirely sure I'm gonna be actually good
thank you okay
so now I got that and now I can oh I
thought that was gonna be a trap or
something
I'm guessing knitting I'm guessing this
one what the hell is wrong with that
thing well thank you for the gift but
I'm trying to wonder what the hell is
wrong with that
oh my god that's gonna haunt my
nightmares that is just regarde damn
dick ulis okay Kabam curse plan is that
you good oh no it's so cool this so
creative how does anyone come up with
this crap maker is supposed to be oh man
that's so cool
oh it's so cool okay so now that I got
it good relatively easy level out of the
way even though I was a little confused
in the beginning there I will get a hard
level now hard not Ross level apart it
doesn't need to be that hard to be fun
it could be a little challenging I guess
there's a reason why Nintendo has been
so successful and everything they've
been doing so this particular person
this lady here is actually the number
one most starred level creator in all of
Super Mario maker and she's got a
of levels Oh oh wow that is a lot of
stars in it kind of clear rate oh I
forgot the control there we go world
record is two seconds goddamn I don't
know if I can do that but I'm gonna give
it a go I don't know if I'm gonna
succeed but I have a funny feeling I'm
gonna fail spectacularly at least it'll
be fun in that regard hello I forgot
there are actually graphics in this game
well what I expect it's adventure okay
so down here nope that's also not
correct Oh No
is there some kind of stratagem that I'm
not supposed to be known about here oh
joy I'm stupid oh this is where my
intelligence gets reflected of how low
it is oh no my this is gonna be bad oh
it's a twenty-three percent clear rate
how am I not good at this
stanky Oh snuffles OH
flutter bump hey nope that's probably
not I imagine what I gotta do is I get a
twirl jump something tells me I might
not actually be on the right course here
Oh such a genius but I feel accomplished
that's my victory screech what's so cool
I feel so good about myself am I
supposed to feel good after I play this
game cuz I do oh my god that was amazing
it was so fun there was another one up
here that was
I don't know if this one's gonna be
harder nah 57% oh that looks oh that
looks fun that looks fun am i playing
games for fun okay the crazy world is
this Oh what am I doing with my life
oh hey wait oh oh God I was it's one of
those Auto doers ah let's just enjoy the
ride here why is it happening why are
cats assisting me in my discharge didn't
rain oh my god
oh it was like three seconds long but it
was like the best three seconds of my
life just like the first time I had
everyone I can't see what it is it looks
interesting you know what I'm gonna go
blind faith wow that's not a whole lot
going on there
I guess what she does is she plays a lot
of she makes a lot of levels that have
like are short and simple and I know I
got the emo hair going on I need a
haircut real badly what am I supposed to
do their secret huh secret doodad huh
Oh No what's with the grandfather clocks
oh boy oh no oh no the hide block is
here I'll load up porpoise hork lot of
these are in Japanese I don't know how
to read that I can't do this stupid
stupid
I don't feel accomplished stupid I'm
just a big bowl of dumb don't mind me I
don't know yeah this is like it's not
helpful
I'll show you like the comments like
I'll show you says the hide block is
here winky face can I cycle through if I
die I think I know what it is
I think I know this is a whole Japanese
this is not helpful none of this is
of all time it contains spoilers you
know what I'm not gonna spoil it because
I think I know what it is I think I know
why the world record is 27 seconds and
it says 476 if the clock which act get
out of here get out of here get out of
here get out of here there we go
if the clock if I wait patiently which I
have not doing and I am not good at that
if I wait patiently until the clock
reaches 476 without taking the one coin
that is oh so tantalizingly there then
there might be a special dammit I
thought that maybe there was like a time
gating mechanism that was gonna be that
way I'm such a failure okay do it
everyone make fun of me in the comments
below for not being able to do this one
I'll go take my failure somewhere else
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna play more Mario maker
and I'm gonna play Mario maker playing
cool interesting levels that may be
challenging and maybe cool and
interesting and challenging so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see
get your face out of my butt please
thank you